ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen noch
ein paar Stunden dann ist Schluss mit
der Atomkraft in Deutschland und damit
geht eine
Ära zu Ende die vor mehr als 60 Jahren
begann
Anfang der 60er Jahre Start für das
erste deutsche Atomkraftwerk das
Versprechen war groß Atomstrom als
saubere Energiequelle für Deutschland
trotzdem gab es von Anfang an auch
Kritik vor allem die Frage wohin mit dem
Atommüll sorgte in den 70er und 80er
Jahren für bundesweite Massenproteste am
Samstag jetzt also werden die letzten
drei Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
und auch wenn ihr vielleicht sagt ist
doch sowieso alles entschieden dann
bleibt die Frage ist das richtig oder
war das vielleicht ein großer Fehler was
sagt ihr dazu schreibt uns eure
Kommentare wie immer in die Kommentare
oder wenn ihr die ZDF heute App nutzt an
die eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute - live als zdf.de
wir freuen uns nicht nur über eure
Kommentare sondern auch auf eure Fragen
an die zwei Herren die wir heute
eingeladen haben das ist zum einen
Professor Volker quaschnik von der
Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft
HTW Berlin sein Fachgebiet sind
regenerative Energien und er hat unter
anderem scientists for future
mitgegründet schön dass Sie dabei sind
Herr quatschen ihre These ist es ist gut
jetzt aus der Atomenergie auszusteigen
und mit dabei ist der
CSU-Generalsekretär Martin Huber
zugeschaltet aus München guten Abend
Herr Huber ihre Haltung ist wir sollten
die Kraftwerke nicht jetzt abschalten
sondern noch länger laufen lassen
Herr Huber fangen wir mit Ihnen an das
sind die letzten Stunden in denen
mutmaßlich auch aus Ihrer Steckdose oder
in ihre Steckdose Atomstrom kommt wie
geht's Ihnen damit
ich halte das Abschalten für einen
großen Fehler den wir erleben ja dass
wir schon eine Stromknappheit haben und
dass wir natürlich gerade auch
angesichts der großen Herausforderungen
des Klimawandels doch nicht auf
Kohlekraftwerke setzen können sondern
auch durchaus noch die Kernkraft hätten
länger nutzen müssen und insofern war ja
auch unsere Forderung immer klar die
drei Kernkraftwerke die noch am Netz
sind länger laufen zu lassen auch um zu
vermeiden dass wir wieder mehr
Kohlestrom in unseren letzten Wochen
ist das für sie ein Tag zum feiern heute
oder morgen muss man ja genauer sagen
zum Feiern naja es war absehbar wir
haben ja seit Jahren über die
Kernenergie gestritten und aus gutem
Grund haben wir uns ja von der
Kernenergie verabschiedet wir haben ja
vor gut zehn Jahren den Ausstieg
vereinbart nachdem wir gesehen haben
dass wir in fukushiba einfach eine
Hochtechnologie haben also einfach
wirklich was passieren kann die Mehrheit
der Deutschen hat es dann auch strikt
abgelehnt auch die CSU war damals ganz
dagegen dass wir die gerne weiterlaufen
lassen soll nur hat es die letzte
Regierung halt einfach versäumt
rechtzeitig solaren Wind Energie
auszubauen so dass man jetzt noch drüber
diskutieren kann hätte man eigentlich
das was man damals hätte machen sollen
Solar und Wind Energie ordentlich
ausgebaut auch in Bayern dann hätten wir
heute gar nicht Diskussionen dann werden
wir jetzt komplett dann hätten wir die
Kernkraftwerke wahrscheinlich schon
vorher abgeschaltet wir werden sie bei
dem jetzigen Ausbau Tempo sowieso nicht
mehr als zwei drei Jahre betreiben
können dann ist auch das technisch gar
nicht mehr sinnvoll möglich und insofern
ist aus meiner Sicht der Zeitpunkt jetzt
auch gerade richtig
sie haben beide in ihren Antworten schon
das große Fächer die den großen Fächer
aufgemacht das ist ein weites Feld das
Thema Atomausstieg wir wollen darüber
sprechen ob wir uns Sorgen machen müssen
das mit dem Ausstieg nicht genug Strom
da ist wir wollen uns fragen ob wir
damit dem Klimaschaden Herr Huber sie
haben das auch gerade angesprochen und
wir wollen uns vor allem auch erstmal
fragen wie es die anderen machen und
dazu werfen wir jetzt gemeinsam mal
einen Blick in die anderen europäischen
Länder wie dies mit der Atomkraft halten
am Karlsruhe Institut für Technologie
forschen Sie weiterhin an nuklearer
Sicherheit es geht aktuell um das
langfristige Wärmeverhalten von
Brennelementen im Zwischenlager wo sie
vielleicht 60 Jahre länger bleiben
werden als zunächst geplant generell
beurteilen Sie hier die Atomkraft als
beherrschbare Technik auch wenn der
Ausstieg kein Fehler sein wir haben
jetzt ja natürlich den Druck der
Erneuerbaren möglichst schnell weiter zu
entwickeln Speichertechnologien zu
entwickeln andere Länder wie in
Frankreich Finnland auch Tschechien
betreiben Kernkraftwerke weiter und
insgesamt in Europa könnte damit
vielleicht ja so waren sehr sehr CO2
Arme Energiemix entstehen
in Frankreich soll kommendes Jahr der
dritte Block des AKW flomanwil in
Betrieb gehen nicht so weit ist das
britische Atomkraftwerk hinklypoint bei
beiden verlängerte sich die Bauzeit weit
über zehn Jahre weil vervielfachten
Kosten Atomkraft ist teuer hingli point
kostet umgerechnet mehr als 30
Milliarden Euro
im Großbritannien sehen wir den Fall
dass die britische Regierung dem
zukünftigen Betreiber des Kernkraftwerks
sehr hohe stromabnahmepreise für die
nächsten 30 Jahre garantieren muss damit
eben Unternehmen bereit sind
Atomkraftwerke zu bauen
mit 14 Jahren Verspätung geht der
finnische Reaktor in olki luuto diese
Tage in Betrieb in den Nachbarschaft
entsteht das Atome entlager Finnlands
infinit 50m tief in am Ende landen die
Brennelemente in solchen Hohlräumen bin
in zwei Jahren soll ein Probebetrieb
beginnen in der Frage des Endlagers sind
fast alle anderen Atom Nationen hinten
dran Deutschland sucht noch den Standort
zum Thema Endlager kommen wir später
auch noch erstmal aber Herr Huber ihre
Stellungnahme zu einem Statement von
einem User namens Michael Dautzenberg
der schreibt über Facebook Länder auf
der ganzen Welt rüsten sogar mit neuen
Kernkraftwerken auf nur Deutschland will
wieder die Welt retten was ist ihre
Meinung dazu
in der festen Überzeugung dass wir
natürlich beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien Vorankommen müssen und bis wir
soweit sind dass wir die erneuerbaren
Energien in so einem Umfang haben wie
wir sie brauchen brauchen wir natürlich
auch eine Brückentechnologie das ist ja
genau der Punkt um den es geht und
deswegen geht auch gar nicht wo sie
darum dass wir neue Kernkraftwerke bauen
sondern es geht darum dass wir die drei
Kernkraftwerke die jetzt noch am Netz
sind länger laufen lassen plus 3 wird
schon vom Netz gegangen sind vielleicht
noch als Reserve mitnutzen der Chef vom
TÜV hat ja deutlich gemacht er sieht
kein Problem darin die Kernkraftwerke
noch bis zum Ende des Jahrzehnts laufen
zu lassen und das würde uns natürlich
ermöglichen dass wir auch einen
Grundlast wegen Strom haben und deswegen
brauchen wir ja einerseits den Aufbau
der erneuerbaren Energien wir schreiben
dann Bayern kraftvoll voran wir sind
übrigens auch in vielen Bereichen ganz
vorne mit dabei aber bis wir soweit sind
dass wir eben diese grundlastfähigkeit
insgesamt auch sicherstellen können bis
dahin brauchen wir eben auch eine Brücke
und genau deswegen haben wir ja auch
damals beschlossen dass wir die
Kraftwerke als Brücke nutzen um die
Erneuerbaren auszubauen und die
Gaskraftwerke als Brücke zu nutzen um
die grundlastfähigkeit herzustellen das
klappt jetzt nicht mehr mit dem Gas und
deswegen brauchen wir eben die Atomkraft
noch länger am Netz um eben auch die
grundlastfähigkeit zu gewährleisten zum
Thema Versorgungssicherheit schauen wir
auch gleich drauf aber erstmal noch ein
quaschnik auf ihre Meinung zum
internationalen Vergleich ist es richtig
alle anderen setzen auf Atomkraft machen
es richtig die deutschen steigen aus und
machen es damit falsch also diese
Diskussion hören wir auch alle fünf bis
zehn Jahre dass alle anderen auf die
Kern in die Gesetzen wenn wir uns
einfach mal die Zahlen anschauen wie
weltweit die Leistung der Kernkraftwerke
sich entwickeln dann sehen wir dass sie
seit 1990 fast gar nicht angestiegen ist
das heißt es werden de facto eigentlich
immer so viele Kernkraftwerke
stillgelegt wie neu gebaut werden da tut
sich nicht sehr viel wir haben einen
sehr dynamischen Ausbau wo erneuerbaren
Energien in drei Jahren wird die
Photovoltaik weltweit mehr Strom liefern
als die Kernenergie die Windkraft ist da
auch schon dabei das heißt also die
Kernenergie ist im Rücklauf und auch
jedenfalls die Zahlen oder die Länder
jetzt sehen also auch Großbritannien
oder Frankreich also Großbritannien hat
ja auch in den letzten Jahren
Kernkraftwerke stillgelegt mehr als da
jetzt irgendwie dazu gebaut wird und
wenn wir uns Frankreich anschauen da
haben wir jetzt irgendwie Kraftwerke
mehrere Dutzend die in den nächsten
Jahren die Altersgrenze erreichen werden
und selbst die wird Frankreich mit dem
Neubau nicht nicht ersetzen können das
heißt also diese diese Story das alle
jetzt weltweit auf die Kerne Energie
setzen wenn man sich die nackten Zahlen
anguckt die stimmen nicht und in den
Ländern teuer
eine eine Sache dazu die EU verschiedene
Länder der EU 12 an der Zahl haben eine
atomkooperation beschlossen um sich in
dieser Stelle zu vernetzen und besser
voranzukommen hat sich Deutschland da
selber abgehängt
man muss am Ende sieht dann auch die
Zahlen anschauen also das heißt wir
haben wir reden ja seit vielen Jahren
Polen wollte in 1980 schon in
Kernkraftwerk bauen die haben jetzt eine
Ruine im Land stehen weil die nicht
fertig gebaut wurde jetzt fängt man
wieder ja 30 40 Jahre vor dann danach
wieder an diese Anlagen in Angriff zu
nehmen da muss man am Ende schauen was
gebaut wird weil in dem Beitrag haben
wir es ja gesehen die kann Energie ist
sehr teuer in Frankreich hat das dazu
geführt dass der französische
Atomkonzern ETF im letzten Jahr 18
Milliarden Verlust gemacht hat er musste
komplett verstaatlicht werden damit er
nicht pleite geht mit 65 Milliarden
Schulden die mittlerweile aufgehäuft
sind also das heißt da müssen wir
erstmal hinschauen also es wird gerne
über gerne in die geredet aber wenn dann
am Ende bezahlt werden soll dann
erledigt erledigen sich dann auch sehr
sehr viele Projekte
einen Zuschauer greift Frankreich hier
auch noch mal auf Frank K ist der
Meinung nein die Atomkraft produziert zu
hohe Kosten sie ist zu gefährlich
außerdem wo bleibt der Atommüll schon
vergessen Frankreich da ist das
Stichwort hat wegen Wassermangel große
Probleme die AKWs zu kühlen das ist die
Meinung dieses Users dann schauen wir
vom internationalen Vergleich jetzt mal
auf die Lage in Deutschland und stellen
uns die Frage nach der
Versorgungssicherheit Herr Huber auch
das haben sie gerade schon angerissen
müssen wir uns Sorgen machen dass wir
jetzt zu wenig Strom haben
schauen Sie wir haben aktuell drei
Kernkraftwerke am Netz die rein
rechnerisch 10 Millionen Haushalte mit
versorgen und zwar grundlastfähig und
der Punkt ist ja nicht so sehr wie viel
Strom erzeugen wir insgesamt im Jahr
betrachtet da kommt dann immer das
Argument na ja wir exportieren ja Strom
aber entscheidend ist ja auch wird der
Strom dann erzeugt wenn ich ihn brauche
das nützt mir ja nichts wenn ich am
Sonntag Nachmittag um 14 Uhr bei Wind an
der Küste und strahlenden Sonnenschein
im Land eine Überproduktion an Strom
habt die ich dann gar nicht verwenden
kann und gleichzeitig habe ich dann bei
Windstille an der Küste und wenig
Sonnenschein am Montag morgen um 8 Uhr
für die Industrie und für den
Wirtschaftsstandort zu wenig Strom das
ist ja genau das Problem bei der
Volatilität und genau deswegen ist eine
grundlastfähige Versorgung schon sehr
wichtig und hier drohen wir natürlich
schon auf Engpässe zuzusteuern erste
diese Woche war ja auch ein Artikel im
Handelsblatt zu lesen in dem Stand
selbst wenn wir 100% des notwendigen
Strombedarfs an installiert der Leistung
hätten mit Photovoltaik und Wind dann
würde das immer noch dazu führen dass
wir in 5000 Stunden im Jahr also
umgerechnet an über 200 Tagen eine
Unterdeckung haben also das heißt die
erneuerbaren Energien brauchen natürlich
auch ein entsprechende Absicherung mit
einer grundlastfähigen Stromerzeugung
das kann die Kernkraft als
Brückentechnologie sein und insofern
brauchen wir eben auch dazu den Ausbau
von Speichern beispielsweise von
wasserstoffinfrastruktur aber wenn wir
jetzt die drei Kernkraftwerke vom Netz
nehmen ist für mich erstens klar das
Angebot am Strommarkt wird verringert
die Nachfrage nach Strom wird steigen da
weiß dann jeder nach den Gesetzen des
Marktes das wird dann auch die
Stromkosten nach oben treiben und
insofern ist das nach wie vor für mich
eine fatale Fehlentscheidung jetzt in
dieser Phase die drei Kernkraftwerke vom
Netz zu nehmen ich lass gerne
Handwaschmittel als Experten darauf
antworten möchte nur noch einen Input
mitgeben die Bundesnetzagentur sagt die
Versorgungssicherheit ist nicht
gefährdet bitte
ja wir haben es ja gesehen wir haben in
diesem Winter oder vor diesem Winter
sehr stark über Versorgungssicherheit
und Engpässe diskutiert wir haben jetzt
noch mal analysiert wie die
Stromversorgung in diesem Winter gewesen
ist und da hätten wir auch ohne
Kernkraftwerke keinerlei Probleme gehabt
also das steht erstmal sicher und im
nächsten Winter werden natürlich auch
die Risiken die wir haben gerade jetzt
mit der Energiekrise deutlich kleiner
sein also Versorgungsengpässe sind nicht
zu erwarten und ich möchte das Argument
von Herrn Huber mit der
grundlastfähigkeit mal wieder legen weil
da ist es Energie technisch kompletter
Nonsens weil wir müssen einfach schauen
wenn wir die solaren Windenergie
ausbauen dann haben wir sehr
fluktuierende in Erzeugung und wir sehen
gerade aus Klimaschutz Gründen müssen
wir ja die solaren Wind Energie sehr
schnell ausbauen das heißt wir werden in
zwei drei Jahren in die Situation kommen
dass wir gerade im Frühjahr tagsüber
100% erneuerbare Energien haben vor
allen Dingen mit der Solarenergie und
dann müssten die Kernkraftwerke in ein
Betriebsmodus gehen den sie gar nicht
beherrschen nämlich Stop and Go man
müsste sie vormittags abschalten
nachmittags wieder anschalten und das
geht nicht das heißt also dann würde man
solaren Windkraftanlagen ab Regeln um
die Kernkraft durchlaufen zu lassen und
alleine aus diesem Grund ist die Zeit
die wir die Kernkraftwerke noch
technisch sinnvoll einsetzen können sehr
sehr überschaubar und dafür dieses Fass
aufzumachen das verstehe ich einfach
nicht warum man das dann diskutiert ich
gucke hier gerade mal in die ja genau
erwähnt hat wenn es eine Stromknappheit
gibt dann müsste man halt zuerst
Wärmepumpen und die Elektromobilität
Ladestationen ausschalten also die
Bundesnetzagentur beschäftigt sich schon
durchaus auch sehr konkret mit einer
Frage was passiert denn wenn der Strom
knapp wird
ich gucke gerade mal in die Kommentare
sehe pro und contra argumente Simone
Georg schreibt und über Facebook zum
Beispiel ich halte den deutschen
Atomausstieg nicht für einen Fehler eine
Stimme
dagegen hat Hertha Lukas sie schreibt
auch über Facebook ja das ist ein Fehler
wir kaufen lieber dann wieder zu teuren
Preisen aus anderen Ländern das ist die
Meinung dieser Userin sie haben den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren angesprochen und
ich möchte gerne mal darauf blicken ähm
Herr Huber was Bayern also ihr Freistaat
dazu beiträgt sie haben ja gesagt sie
sind ganz vorne dabei und das genau
können wir uns mit Zahlen noch mal
anschauen wir haben eine Grafik
vorbereitet und wenn man sich den Ausbau
und die damit erzielte Leistung der
erneuerbaren Energien in absoluten
Zahlen ansieht dann ist Bayern vor
Niedersachsen Nordrhein-Westfalen
führend schließlich Holstein kommt in
absoluten Zahlen nur auf Platz sechs
wenn man die Leistung von Solar und Wind
Energie allerdings in Relation zu der
Fläche bringt dann sieht die Grafik ein
bisschen anders aus hier bringt
schließlich Holstein am meisten Leistung
und Bayern liegt abgeschlagen auf Rang 9
Herr Huber ist das Problem mit der
Versorgungssicherheit auch ein
hausgemachtes weil sie in Bayern den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren einfach nicht
genug vorangetrieben haben
schauen Sie das was Sie hier in den Raum
stellen des stimmt ja nicht selbst der
Robert Habeck musste er auf eine Anfrage
der ceso Landesgruppe ja eingestehen
dass das keinen Bundesland so viel Strom
aus erneuerbaren Energien erzeugt wird
wird es im Freistaat Bayern der Fall ist
und ich darf immer wieder auch darauf
hinweisen dass wir gerade in Bayern
einen sehr breiten Mix haben an
erneuerbaren Energien wir haben
Photovoltaik wir haben Wasserkraft wir
haben Biomasse wir haben Termine wir
haben auch Wind wir sind beispielsweise
was sie dieses Jahr betrifft beim Zubau
an Windenergie auf Platz 5 wir planen
beispielsweise auch in meiner Heimat im
sehr Energie intensiven bayerischen
Chemiebereich einen der größten
Windparks mit der 30 bis 40
Windkraftanlagen das hängt natürlich
auch damit zusammen dass die neuen
Windkraftanlagen mit einer Höhe von 220
Metern auch deutlich effizienter sind
und deswegen auch in Bayern die Flächen
die für Windkraft in Frage kommen auch
zunehmen denn man darf einfach nicht
vergessen die ersten Anlagen mit 60 bis
80 m Höhe in einer Ausgestaltung wo es
oftmals auch mit topografisch möglich
war Windkraft zu nutzen das ist jetzt
mit den neuen Anlagen anders auch
deswegen werden immer bei der
Windenergie deutlich zu liegen ganz kurz
weil sie die Zahlen gerade angesprochen
haben das waren Zahlen unter anderem die
wir recherchiert haben auf Grundlage
eines faktenchecks den der Bayerische
Rundfunk gemacht hat der hat nämlich mal
die Behauptungen gecheckt die aus der
bayerischen Staatsregierung immer wieder
zum Ausbau gekommen sind also nur das
als Grundlage der Zahlen und wir können
es auch gerne noch mal nachrechnen und
in den Chat stellen und sie weil sie das
mit der Windkraft gerade gesagt haben
sie haben sich ja bei Markus Lanz sehr
schwer getan die Frage zu beantworten
wie viel
Windkraftanlagen in den letzten Jahren
in Bayern gebaut worden sind sie können
es hier gerne noch mal sagen wenn Sie
möchten schauen Sie ich weiß ja ganz
genau worauf sie raus wollen und ich
wusste natürlich auch ganz genau worauf
Markus Lanz raus will nur das ganze
führt natürlich in die Irre denn wenn
Sie beispielsweise Strom
Gestehungskosten haben von 13 für die
Kilowattstunde bei Windkraft offer und
sie haben bis zu sind Strom
Gestehungskosten für die Kilowattstunde
an Land in Bayern dann ist doch für
jeden Investor völlig klar wo er sich
zuerst mal überlegt wo er in Windkraft
investiert das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass die Behörden Windkraft in Bayern
verhindern das ist schlicht und
ergreifend eine Frage gewesen wo lohnt
es sich denn am meisten in die Windkraft
zu investieren und deswegen möchte ich
diesen Punkt schon noch mal bringen weil
wir jetzt eben auch höhere
Windkraftanlagen haben und je mehr die
Höhe zunimmt der Windkraftanlagen desto
mehr nimmt auf exponentiell natürlich
die
Windstärke zu und deswegen haben wir
jetzt eben auch mit diesen neuen Anlagen
mehr Flächen die überhaupt in Frage
kommen ich kann ihn nur sagen wenn
jemand das Dreifache an Strom
Gestehungskosten hat für die
Kilowattstunde mit Windkraft in Bayern
als in anderen Bundesländern das ist
doch völlig klar wo stärker in Windkraft
investiert wird und gleichzeitig sind
wir eben auch in Bayern mit einem
starken Mix ausgestattet von
Photovoltaik biomastik irgendwas
bevor sie antworten ganz kurz an sie
beide ihre ihr Meinungsaustausch regt
auch unsere Community sehr dazu an die
Meinungen auszutauschen ich sehe in den
Chat sehr viel
Kommentare Pro und Contra und Eduard
Kuhnt bedankt sich bei uns finde ich
sehr gut dass sie einen Experten und
einen ausstiegsgegner in der Sendung
haben solche trialoge finde ich wichtig
um alle Meinungen abzudecken das an
dieser Stelle nur als Feedback an Sie
und jetzt verquatschen irgendwas ist
ihre Position zum Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren naja auch in Bayern wenn
man den Gesamtenergie Kuchen sich
anguckt dann ist man da auch nicht
deutlich mehr als 20% erneuerbar das
heißt man muss jetzt bei der
Energiewende beim Klimaschutz sich mal
überlegen wo der Rest herkommen soll und
bei der Solarenergie klar liegt Bayern
vorne hat aber auch die besten
Bedingungen bei der Nutzung der
Solarenergie hier in Deutschland aber
wenn man sich die anderen erneuerbaren
anguckt und vor allen Dingen die
Windenergie da sieht es halt einfach
nicht so gut aus weil bei der
Windenergie Bayern hat auch einen Winter
und muss sich überlegen wie sie künftig
den Winter überdecken sollen und wenn
man die kann sich anschaut das ist ja
richtig dass also wir leichte
Unterschiede haben was die was die
Wirtschaftlichkeit anbelangt aber bei
der Vergütung sieht es auch so aus dass
wir in Süddeutschland auch höhere
Vergütungen kriegen für Windkraftanlagen
trotzdem wurde wenig gebaut und das lag
jetzt nicht unbedingt an der
Wirtschaftlichkeit sondern auch im
Wesentlichen über die flächenkulisse in
Bayern hat man eine 10h-regel
beschlossen mit der man so große
Abstände zu Windrädern einhalten muss
dass man de facto fast ein Großteil des
Landes auswichsen muss und kaum mehr
Standorte hat wir haben Anfang dieses
Jahres im ersten Quartal in Bayern nur
zwei neue Windkraftanlagen genehmigt das
heißt also mit dem Tempo wird deutlich
wird Bayern in den nächsten 500 Jahren
nicht Klima neutral werden können und da
muss man sich was überlegen und da hilft
das auch nicht ein Kernkraftwerk in
Bayern weiterlaufen zu lassen auch das
hilft nicht das heißt wir müssen
wirklich schauen den Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien voranzubringen und nicht nur in
Norddeutschland sondern es muss auch im
Süden funktionieren und nicht nur bei
der Photovoltaik weil dann kommen wir
nämlich nicht über den Winter das eine
Kern das
ähm das eine Kernkraftwerk das in Bayern
morgen abgeschaltet wird dieser zwei das
hat der bayerische Ministerpräsident
Markus Söder gestern besucht und er hat
heute eine klare Haltung zum Thema
Kernkraft wir schauen gerade mal auf
einen Tweet von ihm von heute hier
twittert Markus Söder der Ausstieg aus
der Kernkraft ist eine absolute
Fehlentscheidung während in vielen
Ländern der weltkernkraft sogar
ausgebaut wird macht Deutschland genau
das Gegenteil das ist also die Haltung
von Markus Söder heute für alle die dies
möglicherweise vergessen haben schauen
wir uns seine Haltung aus dem Jahr 2011
noch einmal an damals war nämlich die
CSU eine Speerspitze beim Atomausstieg
Fukushima endet alles vor allem die
Bewertung des westrisikos das ist ja das
Ereignis des uns dazu gezwungen hat
einfach völlig neu zu überlegen und ich
kann nur für mich sein ich würde dieses
Rest Risiko über Generationen Weg so
nicht mehr tragen wollen
ja also Herr Huber wir sehen da hat sich
die Position verändert wie viel
Wahlkampf bayerischer Landtagswahlkampf
steckt denn in der Argumentation heute
über den Atomausstieg da steckt
überhaupt kein Wahlkampf drin sondern es
steckt die Erkenntnis drin dass sich die
Situation ganz elementar geändert hat
und dass wir ich kann so noch mehr sagen
als Ergebnis aus dem Atomausstieg
natürlich darauf gesetzt haben
Gaskraftwerke als Brücke zu verwenden
durch den Krieg Russland gegen die
Ukraine ist das jetzt so dass wir
natürlich auch beim Thema Gas und neu
justieren müssen und dass wir natürlich
deswegen auch eine Brücke brauchen bis
insgesamt die erneuerbaren Energien so
stark ausgebaut sind wie wir es brauchen
und deswegen hat sich wie gesagt die
Situation massiv geändert und deswegen
ist es eben auch vernünftiger aus
unserer Sicht dass wir die
Kernkraftwerke länger am Netz lassen um
eben auch die notwendige Strommenge
führt Zeugen denn es kann ja auch nicht
sein dass wir in Zeiten des Klimawandels
lieber auf dreckige Kohlekraftwerke
setzen anstatt auch CO2 neutrale
Kernkraft Netzwerke selbst Greta
Thunberg hat darauf hingewiesen es wäre
besser Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu lassen
anstatt der Kohlekraftwerke und wenn
Robert Habeck in der Ukraine sagt
Kernkraftwerke in der Ukraine sind in
Ordnung aber in Deutschland schalten wir
Sie ab dann habe ich schon den Eindruck
dass es hier nicht um Fakten geht das
ist hier nicht um eine sachliche
Argumentation geht sondern dass da
einfach ideologische Gründe im
Vordergrund stehen
bleiben wir noch mal bei der Politik wir
haben Herrn Söder gerade gesehen und
seine 180 Grad Wände und wir haben auch
gesehen dass die Politik damals den
Ausstieg beschlossen hat und bei den
Erneuerbaren kann man jetzt darüber
diskutieren wie wir es gerade getan
haben offenbar nicht genug gesehen hat
wo hat die Politik da versagt
naja wir sehen ja so eine gewisse Risiko
Demenz die wir in Deutschland haben ich
meine das sind die gleichen
Kernkraftwerke mit dem gleichen
Restrisiko das heißt die Argumente von
Herrn Söder von damals die müssten heute
ja auch noch gelten wir haben ja hier
keine andere Technologie im Einsatz nur
wir haben halt einfach ein bisschen Zeit
und nun ist die Hoffnung dass nie wieder
was bei der Kernenergie passiert das ist
ja ein Trugschluss und wir werden
irgendwann in den nächsten zehn Jahren
vermutlich Ereignisse weltweit sehen wo
wir in Deutschland halt froh sein werden
dass wir aus dieser Technologie raus
sind weil es gibt natürlich einen Rest
Risiko und das wird irgendwo wieder
zuschlagen deswegen gehen wir ja auch
aus dieser Technologie raus und nicht
aus ideologischen Gründen so und ähm das
ist erstmal relativ wichtig und dann
müssen wir natürlich wie gesagt schauen
dass wir bei der Energiewende
vorankommen und dass wir klimaneutral
werden und wenn man bei der Kernenergie
über Klimaschutz redet ja dann muss man
sich auch da mal die nackten Zahlen
anschauen wir haben im letzten Jahr mit
der Kernen die im Strombereich gut 6 %
abgedeckt der Strom macht aber nur ein
Fünftel des energieaufkommens aus das
heißt wir haben noch die Wärme den
Verkehr die Industrie und wenn wir über
alle Sektoren hinweg schauen sich die
Kernenergie oder lag im letzten Jahr die
Kernenergie beim guten Prozent in
Deutschland das ist der Anteil den man
zum Klimaschutz haben wir haben 80%
fossile Energien und nun kann man doch
nicht sagen dass wir jetzt ein
Kernkraftwerk weiterlaufen lassen weil
wir uns noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen
bei der Energiewende und weiterhin auch
diese 80 Prozent fossilen haben das
heißt wir müssen jetzt wirklich Tempo
machen bei den erneuerbaren und sobald
man Tempo bei den erneuerbaren Energien
macht ist die Kernenergie als nicht gut
regelbare Technologie nicht mehr als
überbrückungstechnologie geeignet das
heißt wer auf die Kernenergie länger
setzt setzt auch darauf dass der Ausbau
erneuerbare Energie weiter so langsam
stattfindet und dann müssen wir gleiche
bauen und nicht über Kernen Energie
reden
ganz oft haben sie beide schon das Thema
Klimaschutz angesprochen und Jens Spahn
hat heute gesagt das ist ein schwarzer
Tag für den Klimaschutz in Deutschland
heute darüber möchte ich jetzt gerne
sprechen Schaden wir dem Klima wenn wir
nicht doch noch übergangsweise auf
Atomkraft setzen und schauen dabei auch
weil man das gar nicht ausklammern kann
auf die Frage nach dem Atom Müll ein
kleiner Blick in die deutsche Geschichte
der Atomkraft
juni 1961 das erste deutsche
Atomkraftwerk geht im bayerischen Carl
ans Netz Regierung und Teile der
Bevölkerung setzen große Hoffnungen in
die neue vermeintlich saubere
Energieform 16 Megabyte Leistung hat das
Versuchs AKW damals etwa so viel wie das
größte Windrad heutzutage die
Energiekonzerne bauen mehr und
leistungsstärkere AKW Ende der 1980er
Jahre der Höhepunkt insgesamt 28
Reaktoren sind in Betrieb sie liefern
über Jahre zwischen 30 und 35 Prozent
der Energie parallel zum Ausbau formiert
sich Protest die Angst vor möglichen
Folgen wächst Hauptproblem wohin mit dem
radioaktiven Müll der Beginn einer
rasant wachsenden
in Deutschland
1986 die Katastrophe in Tschernobyl
radioaktive Strahlung verteilt sich in
ganz Europa die Atomenergie in
Deutschland am Wendepunkt durch massive
Proteste der Bevölkerung und die hohen
Kosten für den Bau der Kraftwerke viele
werden abgeschaltet und nicht durch neue
ersetzt
2002 der erste Atomausstieg die
rot-grüne Regierung begrenzt die
Gesamtlaufzeit der AKW auf 32 Jahre
2010 die Entscheidung für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung
doch ein Jahr später die Kehrtwende nach
der Katastrophe im japanischen AKW
Fukushima beschließt der Bundestag den
endgültigen Atomausstieg bis 2022
Deutschland setzt verstärkt auf
erneuerbarer Energie die Kernkraftwerke
werden schrittweise stillgelegt
wegen der Energiekrise im vergangenen
Winter laufen die drei verbliebenen AKW
länger
am 15 April 2023 die endgültige
Abschaltung übrig bleiben rund 650.000
Kubikmeter radioaktiv verseuchter Müll
27.000 davon hoch radioaktiv
ja die Frage nach dem Atom Müll ist eine
der am meisten gestellten hier in den
Chats auch die Frage nach der
Endlagerung und sie wird ganz oft mit
der Frage verknüpfter Huber wo sie in
Bayern denn gerne ein Endlager vor für
Atommüll hätten
schauen Sie das ist ja zunächst einmal
keine politische Frage sondern eine
fachliche Frage es gibt ja die Atommüll
endlagerkommission die sich in ganz
Deutschland damit beschäftigt wo könnte
denn ein Standort sein und diese
Kommission arbeitet ja noch und wird ja
erst in einigen Jahren noch einmal die
Vorschläge konkretisieren und insofern
muss man ja zunächst einmal auch
fachlich prüfen welche Städten welche
Orte denn überhaupt auch in Frage also
spaß beiseite und Bayern beiseite
natürlich muss man aber wenn man über
das Thema Atomkraft und auch über die
Verlängerung nachdenkt darüber sprechen
was mit dem Müll ist das ist auch in
ihrer Argumentation sicherlich
mitgedacht
selbstverständlich und deswegen kann ich
noch mal darauf hinweisen das ist
Aufgabe der Atom endlagerkommission und
der fachlichen Gesichtspunkten sich dem
Thema zu widmen und zu schauen wo sind
denn passende Städten die man in
Deutschland dafür verwenden könnte Herr
Professor eine
Sandra fragt auch wohin mit dem
strahlenden Müll also auch sie
beschäftigt dieses Thema aber
sie auch es ist ein schwarzer Tag für
den Klimawandel oder für den Klimaschutz
muss man wahrscheinlich besser sagen
weil wir Stadt Atomkraft nun
Kohlekraftwerke Nutzen hat sie recht
naja nur zum Teil also wir sehen ja dass
wir im ersten Quartal diesen Jahres mehr
Strom exportiert haben als die
Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland produziert
haben das heißt also wir werden erstmal
durch den Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
weniger Strom exportieren dann muss man
im Ausland schauen welche Kraftwerke
dafür dann angeschmissen werden das
werden nicht immer Kohlekraftwerke sein
sondern das auch andere in Deutschland
werden wir temporär auch fossile Anlagen
übergangsweise brauchen nur wir haben
auch ein sehr schnellen Ausbau der
Solar-Energie derzeit im Fokus und
deswegen werden die erneuerbaren
Energien was ich vorhin schon mal gesagt
habe sehr schnell ausgebaut werden und
sehr schnell hochgefahren werden so dass
man klassische Grundlastkraftwerke wie
die Kernenergie und später auch wie die
Braunkohle gar nicht mehr sinnvoll in
den Energiemix integrieren kann das
heißt wir müssen uns nach der
Kernenergie auch um den
braunkohleausstieg Gedanken machen weil
wir hier wie gesagt technisch
Schwierigkeiten haben und natürlich
brauchen wir dann sehr schnell andere
Lösungen wir müssen dann die Speicher
sehr schnell in den Markt bringen und
das ist jetzt die Aufgabe der jetzigen
Regierung die versäum unter der letzten
20 Jahre aufzuholen im Express Tempo und
wie gesagt selbst wenn wir jetzt heute
entscheiden würden dass wir uns diese
die drei Kernkraftwerke länger laufen
lassen dann bräuchten wir vermutlich
mindestens ein oder vielleicht
anderthalb Jahre bis die dann wieder
betriebsfähig sind in dem Zeitraum sind
wir mit den erneuerbaren Energien schon
so weit dass wir sie wie gesagt nicht
mehr sinnvoll integrieren können und
deswegen werden sie auch gar kein
Betreiber finden der nicht ohne massive
staatliche Zuschüsse und Unterstützung
überhaupt bereit wäre diese Anlagen
laufen zu lassen es sind wirtschaftlich
und technologisch dann mittlerweile
hochrisikoanlagen und deswegen müssen
wir diese Diskussion beenden es ist ein
Prozent was die Kernenergie an Anteil
hat was im Klimaschutz ist das tut
natürlich weh aber das sind andere
Entscheidungen das kann man könnte man
zum Beispiel mit sehr einfachen
Maßnahmen wie zum Beispiel Tempolimit
auch wieder auffangen auch das sind wir
in Deutschland nicht bereit umzusetzen
Herr Huber sie haben bzw die CSU bzw
Markus Söder hat gesagt da ist das
letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen was
haben wir denn da zu erwarten
wir werden natürlich immer darauf achten
müssen dass
die Kernkraftwerke die jetzt vom Netz
gehen natürlich schon auch noch
vorhanden sind ja und dass sie natürlich
jetzt mit dem Rückbau nicht umgehend
beginnen und soll Rückbau der Dauer der
auch gewisse Zeit und deswegen hat ja
auch Markus Söder gestern bei seinem
Besuch in Landshut bei dieser zwei
darauf hingewiesen dass wir natürlich
auch schauen müssen dass wir die
Kernkraftwerke so weit
betriebsfähig halten dass wir sie dann
auch wieder verwenden können wenn sie
gebraucht werden denn ich möchte noch
einen Punkt eingehen den äh quasi auch
gesagt hat wenn wir über Transformation
reden wenn wir über Energiewende reden
dann müssen wir uns doch auch klar
machen dass das bedeutet dass sämtliche
Produktionsprozesse sämtliche Verfahren
die aktuell auf fossilen Energieträgern
passiert umgestellt werden auf
Elektrifizierung umgestellt werden auf
Strom basierte anwenden was ja nichts
anderes bedeutet als dass der Strom
verbraucht der Strombedarf ganz rasant
in die Höhe schnellen wird
ich rechne mal mindestens mit einer
Verdreifachung des Strombedarf fahren
Sie beispielsweise nur die chemische
Industrie in Deutschland wird eine
10-11-fachen Strombedarf haben bei dem
Einstieg in die Wasserstoffwirtschaft
die chemische Industrie braucht
Wasserstoff für auch als Grundstoff für
die Produktion also da haben sie in
Zukunft nur bei der chemischen Industrie
einen Bedarf von 600 Terabyte Stunden
Strom das ist so viel wie jetzt ganz
Deutschland drauf das heißt allein
dadurch hätten sie schon eine
Verdopplung mit denen alles andere noch
mit rein rechnet würde ich mal sagen
muss man mindestens von einer
Verdreifachung des Strombedarfs in
Deutschland ausgeht und bis wir da
soweit sind dass wir das alles abdecken
können mit erneuerbaren Energien
brauchen wir natürlich auch all das was
jetzt verfügbar ist und ich kann nur
noch einmal auch darauf hinweisen
das was wir in Deutschland in Zukunft
brauchen werden das wird eine eine ganz
große Steigerung sein und deswegen
kannst nicht sein wenn ich mir überlege
beispielsweise bei der Studie die
deutlich im handelsplatt war selbst wenn
wir 100% des Bedarf an Strom in
Deutschland an installierter Leistung
hätten mit Photovoltaik und Wind hätten
wir immer noch an 200 Tagen im Jahr eine
Unterdeckung das müssen wir irgendwie
überbrücken da hilft uns auch nichts
wenn man am Sonntagnachmittag Strom
woanders in exportieren
Atomkraftwerke gerne weiterlaufen lassen
oder Standby halten dass man sie quasi
wieder anschalten kann wenn man merkt
jetzt brauchen wir doch den Atomstrom
noch dazu sagt der User alpin Wolf das
ist völliger Unsinn die Kraftwerke
bereitzuhalten was sagen sie
ja also wenn man bayerisches Steuergeld
verbrennen will kann man das natürlich
gerne machen also ansonsten wie gesagt
ich sehe nicht dass irgendein Betreiber
sie wieder in Betrieb nimmt und sie sind
ja jetzt auch gar nicht betriebsfähig
das heißt man müsste eine periodische
Sicherheitsüberprüfung machen man müsste
massiv nachrüsten Brennelemente ordern
bevor das nicht passiert ist könnte man
die Anlagen gar nicht mehr einschalten
und um das zu machen müsste man erstmal
vorab sich Millionen oder wahrscheinlich
hunderte von Millionen an Steuergeldern
irgendwie locker machen und die da
reinstecken ansonsten ist das ein rein
symbolischer Akt dass man einfach für
den Wahlkampf wahrscheinlich sich jetzt
als eine starke Mann hinstellt der die
Kernkraftwerke verteidigt aber die sind
ja nicht betriebsbereit die stehen
einfach in der Landschaft rum und werden
halt dann drei Jahre später rückgebaut
das hilft Deutschland relativ wenig und
Bayern vermutlich auch nicht Herr Huber
wenn die Grünen die Kernkraftwerke
länger laufen lassen ist die CSU dann
fürs Tempolimit
sind doch alles Scheindebatten also das
Tempolimit hat doch ich musste ganz kurz
Entschuldigung entschuldigung ich muss
sie ganz kurz daran erinnern dass die
Debatte vor allem von der CSU geführt
wird
nein also die Debatte zum Thema
tempolimitiert eingeführt und das Thema
Tempolimit ist doch wirklich eine
Scheindebatte die auf den Klimaschutz 0,
irgendwas Auswirkungen hat also das ist
doch praktisch kein Effekt
schauen Sie nur mit dem weiterlaufen von
dieser 2 würden sie so viel CO2
einsparen wie ein Drittel des gesamten
der gesamten Mobilität in Deutschland
das sind doch dann eher die Fakten muss
ein Drittel des gesamten
also das zahlen wenn wir dieser zwei
länger laufen lassen und dich dafür und
ich darf schon oft auch hinweisen dass
dieser zwei 35 Jahre lang störungsfrei
gelaufen ist und dass der Chef vom
deutlich darauf hingewiesen hat
natürlich wäre es ohne Probleme mögliche
technisch und auch von den
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen her die drei
Kernkraftwerke bis zum Ende des
Jahrzehnten bitte
ja also wie gesagt von den Mengen her
bitte bleiben Sie dabei also wenn sie
anschauen was der Verkehr an CO2 hat und
was wir in der Kernanlage haben da liegt
dann eine 10er Potenz dazwischen also
das in Relation zu stellen das stimmt
einfach nicht könnte man ja weiß man
nicht ob sie ihren Faktencheck dann
hinterher gibt bei der Sicherheit müssen
wir schauen es ist eine periodische
Sicherheitsüberprüfung bei
Kernkraftwerken vorgesehen die wurde
ausgesetzt weil man einfach jetzt in der
Notlage die Kernkraftwerke schnell
brauchte die muss man natürlich
nachholen wir sehen was in Frankreich
passiert da sind dann Milliardenbeträge
für Nachrüstungen in Frankreich fällig
ähnliches wird vermutlich hier in den
nächsten Jahren auch passiert und das
muss irgendjemand bezahlen also das
heißt ein billiger Betrieb ist es nicht
und der Weiterbetrieb oder alleine die
bereitschaftshaltung von Kernkraftwerken
wird ein sehr sehr teures Unterfangen
sein und dann noch einmal es wird uns
wenig weiterhelfen wir werden bis dahin
mit den erneuerbaren Energien so schnell
vorankommen dass wir die Energiewende
ohne die Kernen Energie besser bereiten
können zumal wir auch in Norddeutschland
heute schon Situationen haben wo wir
Windräder abschalten müssen damit die
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen weil der
Strom einfach nicht mehr durchgeleitet
werden kann sie sehen praktisch im Weg
sind schlecht regelbar und deswegen
macht es einfach Sinn die Erneuerbaren
auszubauen und der große Strombedarf den
Herr uber angesprochen hat der ist
richtig und genau deswegen brauchen wir
auch in Bayern jede erneuerbare
Energieform die funktioniert und auch
Windkraftanlagen und nicht zwei pro
Quartal die genehmigt werden damit
werden wir Deutschland massiv Schaden
und vor allen Dingen auch der
bayerischen Wirtschaft weil die braucht
auch Strom und wenn der Strom von sonst
woher geleitet werden wird dann wird es
für Bayern irgendwann sehr sehr teuer
werden
im Juni diesen Jahres die Ausschreibung
läuft für 30 Windkraftanlagen im
bayerischen gemiedereck wir sind da
wirklich kraftvoll dabei
sagt kraftvoll zum Ende dieser Sendung
der CSU-Generalsekretär Martin Huber
ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie dabei
waren und ich danke Herr Professor
Volker quaschning auch und ich würde
einfach vorschlagen wir haben jetzt so
munter über die Atomkraft diskutiert
lassen Sie uns doch in der gleichen
Runde gerne noch mal über das Tempolimit
diskutieren und ich bin mir sicher dass
die Userin und User genauso angeregt
ihre Fragen stellen und mit kommentieren
und mitzuhören wie bei diesem Stream
vielen herzlichen Dank an sie beide fürs
Mitmachen sehr gerne danke auch schönen
Abend ciao
und das wünschen wir auch Ihnen zu Hause
und wie gesagt beim nächsten Mal gerne
zum Thema Tempolimit oder worüber man
auch sonst diskutieren und sprechen kann
hier bei ZDF heute live machen es ist
gut bis dann tschüss